hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the outlast whistleblower
DLC nice beard or is that just the
entrails of the Fallen on your face did
you microwave his head until his brain
exploded so girls why am I still looking
at this game doesn't rely on a string
quartet oh my back just has a guy
playing a sousaphone in my ear
stop that sousaphone man oh I moved his
door so sorry that was my bad I probably
scared him poopy and God why is everyone
being so mean to me
I'm not even human whoa oh my god holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I am out good golly
that was the most disturbing thing I've
seen in a game good I'm not one to stop
your love through that room oh really
did she hear about my beatable skills
how are the horse is so freaking calm
panic